to keep the pressure Jaylen Williams
somehow fighting through that traffic
hangs in the air long enough and Banks
it in that's another big time shot by a
big time player to keep the pressure on
the Nuggets where the playmaking in this
game has been elevated to a whole
another level as the Nuggets going to
spread it
out one point Denver lead once again
it's Dort trying to harass Jamal
Murray yic has to heave it up
desperation shot it is short battle for
the rebound and the Thunder have time
the shot clock is off Mark dnal not
using a timeout
SGA probing piercing spinning hanging
for the lead and SJ knocks it
down with just under a second to go the
Thunder finally get the defensive stop
and SGA puts him in
front and they haven't LED since the
early part of the first quarter this run
started at the three-minute
Mark and they came up with the biggest
defensive rebound of the
night Joe getting in there Shay picking
it up and Shay says I got this folks
I've been here before and yes I have oh
you see the El on the bench rightfully
so and what has just been a second half
battle for the Thunder and Shay got his
spot that turnaround he had the go head
shot as we showed
you in January when the thunder came
into this building and stole one away